[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
as a married man you know I look at the
Modern dating scene like someone who ran
out of a burning building seconds before
it collapsed somebody on Twitter
recently said that married people these
days must feel like they caught the last
Chopper out of Nam and perhaps that's
the better analogy whichever image you
prefer the point is that I wake up every
day grateful to be married mostly
because you know I love my wife and my
family but also because I simply could
not be a single man in this environment
I would have already become a monk or a
Hermit in the Woods by now I don't say
this to rub it in the faces of people in
the audience who are single I say it
more as encouragement really for any who
are married because even if you're
struggling in your marriage even if you
and your spouse have hit hard times
consider that the alternative is to
wander alone in this Barren Wasteland
realize that all you have is each other
out there it's dark and cold and you'll
likely die shivering and alone so your
marriage is your shelter be grateful for
it stop screwing it up
do you really want to start over again
in this environment would you really
prefer to be out there dating during the
zombie apocalypse again I'm not trying
to make single people feel bad it's more
that I'm commiserating with you
now many of the problems with modern
dating and with modern culture in
general and dating in general were
highlighted by a recent viral phenomenon
which began on Tick Tock as they often
do and then spread like herpes to other
social media platforms which is where I
became aware of it from what I can tell
it began when a woman used her platform
to vent her frustrations about a man
that she'd recently met on a dating app
called hinge which I didn't even know
existed until I heard about this the man
Caleb took her out on one date
and then never talk to her again
otherwise known as uh ghosting as the
kids call it now other women on Tick
Tock then chimed in with their own
horror stories about the man who had
quickly been dubbed West Elm Caleb a
monarcher based on where he works
and soon his name was trending
Nationwide he had been doxed all across
the internet so here's just uh just to
give you an idea of what this is here's
a quick sample of one of the video
testimonials and there are like hundreds
like this but one of the video
testimonials that you might find
detailing the dastardly crimes of this
Caleb character here it is
I matched with Caleb on hinge and we
started talking we talked for like two
three weeks maybe like nothing serious I
never met this man like literally just
texting Snapchatting whatever
uh same thing happened that everyone's
talking about he was super weird like
started getting very cryptic and
concerning and ghosted so he goes to me
we stop talking
I went my separate way didn't think of
this man you know was nothing really
going on
and then okay so I go on my life I'm
minding my own business until about a
month ago sometime during December
I
see that I have a an Instagram request
DM request or whatever
and who could it be who could it be
him on his new Instagram account not
Caleb Hunter okay
riveting like I told you I'm so glad I'm
not dating anymore with with people like
this this is what you have to deal with
and I'm talking about the woman not even
the guy
now she went on in that video to post
screenshots of the text from Caleb where
he tries to get back into her good
graces After ignoring her for a year she
she turns them down and that's the end
of it so far as I can tell all of the
videos are like this Caleb is guilty of
being rude and tacky and for that
infraction he apparently deserves to be
doxxed and publicly shamed by women who
are all almost certainly at least as
shallow and selfish as he is
so there's a lot that can be said about
the lack of proportionality when the
internet mob sets its sights on someone
local news stories become global
concerns and stories that wouldn't even
be fit to air on the local news or to be
written on a note card and tacked to a
bulletin board somewhere still turn into
National affairs we could say plenty
about that but that's not what we're
focused on today
dating is the issue
and this story reveals it's Myriad
pitfalls in our current climate the
whole scene is is one big pit that so
many millions fall into and never
managed to escape marriage rates are
plummeting rapidly and historically in
this country so that as of two years ago
as of just two years ago less than half
of the households in the U.S consisted
of married couples and families now to
put that in perspective in 1950 that
number was 80 percent
so it used to be 80 of the households
featured a married couple was it was a
family with a married couple now it's
less than half
and the numbers are still trending
downward
there are numerous reasons for this
catastrophic shift but certainly one of
the most prominent reasons is that our
social system for matching people up
pairing them off and setting them on the
path towards marriage and Parenthood and
real adult life is fundamentally broken
so for one thing
everyone of course is using dating apps
now which are which are different even
from the dating sites of ancient times
back in the early 2000s when I was when
I was single we had the dating websites
and back then you would fill out a
lengthy profile and you'd be given in
return
a comparatively small group of potential
matches to contact
but now those old-fashioned websites
have been replaced by apps which are
much easier to use and to peruse and
most people have more than one that they
monitor at any given time it doesn't
require any effort or commitment to use
the apps and the user sort of swipes
through it very quickly casually
discarding potential matches based on
nothing but a cursory glance at their
photograph
so all judgments are made visually which
already distorts the entire process
because a woman's romantic attraction is
not naturally as visually based as a
man's
and that's how a slovenly ogre like
myself ends up marrying a hot woman
because a woman is attracted to
personality sense of humor intelligence
but little of that translates through an
app
which means that many quality mates are
sent to the junk folder just because
they're bad at taking selfies
meanwhile there are far too many choices
so the modern dating scene is what
happens when every beggar becomes a
chooser
everyone is lonely and desperate for
companionship but the field is so
flooded with options there's such a
surplus that you begin to feel like kind
of like I feel when I'm in the condiment
aisle at Walmart trying to buy mustard
and there are 197 different types of
mustard and though all I want is just
regular mustard the overwhelming array
of options paralyzes me and I'm just
standing there slack jawed questioning
whether I should be settling for just
regular mustard when I could be getting
Gourmet Dijon whole grain honey French
yellow spicy brown white yellow German
mustard instead
all of Modern Life is plagued by this
problem everything is plentiful
and can be obtained effortlessly and
cheaply
but it's too plentiful and too
effortless and too cheap
so you can turn on your TV and watch
literally any movie that's ever been
made any TV show that's ever been
produced
and yet how many nights have you wasted
scrolling through the infinite catalog
and then settling on reruns of you know
the office because there's nothing else
to watch
well there's plenty to watch it's just
that you can't settle on any one thing
because your awareness that there are
billions of other possibilities gives
you anxiety and it makes it so that you
can never be sure that you're choosing
the absolute best option
which means that often you don't choose
anything at all so dating is like this
whereas before you had only
the eligible single people in your town
to choose from now you have the entire
internet
you're not confined by Geographic
boundaries or any other boundaries
the result ironically is paralysis
now on the complete opposite end of this
spectrum are arranged marriages instead
of a boundless never-ending Buffet of
options a young person in a culture that
practices arranged marriages will be
assigned just one and they don't even
make the choice
their families just pair them up and say
here you go
there's far less freedom and far less
autonomy in a system of that sort but it
is without a doubt
Superior to our system
we would be happier
every person in the dating scene right
now would be happier if they were just
matched up with someone against their
will actually
of course even after you
settle on a match and you meet them in
person a whole new set of problem arises
it would be impossible to review the
whole list but one of the big problems
is that if you're in the younger
Generations
you're meeting someone who was raised on
the internet just like you
having spent their formative years
staring at screens they oftentimes will
not will not have developed the kind of
interests and hobbies and Rich interior
life that could form the basis for
conversation and for interpersonal
bonding
you also don't know where to go on a
date or what to do because nobody wants
to do anything but stare at their phones
and as the relationship progresses if it
does
you'll find that the internet also
interferes with emotional intimacy
because there's nothing private or
sacred between you
private life private life doesn't exist
anymore especially for younger people
live their whole lives in public
sharing everything with the world
and leaving no parts of themselves
emotionally or very often physically
that are special or exclusive for their
significant others
and then there's the biggest hurdle of
all one which has been standing in the
way ever since the modern concept of
dating was first invented decades ago
but which has only grown larger and more
insurmountable as the decades have gone
by and that is
there's no goal with dating there's no
end point there's no resolution there's
no logical progression
so those women complain about getting
ghosted by Caleb but what are they
really complaining about
did they see him as marriage material
were they even looking for a man to
marry I'm guessing not
and if not then their relationship with
Caleb was was doomed to fall apart
anyway sooner than later
just as all of their other relationships
before and since have
what difference does it make if he
disappears after one date or if he
sticks around and the whole thing
dissolves after three months who cares
you're just hopping into one car after
another and each is going over a cliff
does it really matter if it tumbles over
the edge after one mile or ten
the whole Enterprise is so fundamentally
hopeless and pointless that if anything
the calebs of the world do you a favor
by wasting less of your time
so here's the reality
there's no reason to be dating at all
unless you're specifically looking for
somebody to marry if you have no
interest in marriage then all of your
romantic relationships are doomed before
they start
you're building sand castles during high
tide it's all going to be washed away
before it can be finished
you're making a series of bad emotional
Investments pouring yourself into one
leaky container after another
it's no wonder that marriage rates are
plummeting people are exhausted by
romantic relationships and Jaded by the
whole Enterprise before they even reach
25 years old
because they've been betrayed and
heartbroken and dumped and humiliated
enough for 50 lifetimes
that's what happens when you take the
courtship out of dating
only solution is to put it back in
I mean really forget about dating
completely in fact replace dating with
courting don't waste your time on people
who have no goal for their relationship
because marriage should always be the
desired endpoint courting is the trial
period the interview process that both
partners are undergoing you're
interviewing each other for the job
if you approach a dating that way it
will significantly reduce your options
that's for sure
but as we've seen
that's not necessarily A Bad Thing
does it make sense that the same company
who controls half of online retail also
passively eavesdrops on your private
conversations at home big Tech is more
powerful than most countries are and
they profit by exploiting your personal
data it's time to put a layer of
protection between your online activity
and big Tech and that's why I use
expressvpn think about how much of your
life is on the internet sadly every site
you visit video you watch messages sent
gets tracked and data mined but when you
run expressvpn on your device the
software hides your IP address something
big Tech can use to personally identify
you so expressive again makes your
activity harder to trace and harder to
sell to advertisers there for expressvpn
also encrypts 100 of your internet data
to keep you safe from hackers and
eavesdroppers that are on your network
what I like most about expressvpn is how
easy it is to use you can download the
app on your phone or computer tap one
button and that's it you're protected
expressvpn does all this without showing
or slowing down your connection that's
why it's rated the number one VPN
service by techradar The Verge and
countless others so stop handing all of
your personal data over to the big Tech
Monopoly who Minds your activity and
sells your information protect yourself
with the VPN that I trust to keep me
safe online visit expressvpn.com
walshyt to get three extra months free
there's a little bit of a delayed
reaction but finally yesterday uh
Tuesday The Usual Suspects decided to be
offended by my show on Monday where we
talked about among other things The
Perils of modern dating and as you might
recall during the course of that
conversation I observed that one of the
Myriad problems with the dating scene is
that there are far too many options
which are arranged far too conveniently
and superficially on dating apps for you
to scroll through like you're shopping
for a mate on Amazon or something we've
talked about the familiar uh irony of
Modern Life where the surplus of choices
tends to paralyze us it breeds
indecision and anxiety you know you're
afraid to pick one thing because you're
aware that there are a million other
options how can you know that this is
the right one
why not just hold out for the next one
and the one after that and the one after
that forever
now I'm far from the first person to
point this out as much as I'd like to
take credit for the Insight I certainly
can't the Paradox of choice is something
that many cultural critics and analysts
have noticed over the years in fact one
of them wrote a book called The Paradox
of choice about this very problem
specifically as it relates to Consumers
another book that touches on these
themes which I read a few months ago is
called the world beyond your head by
Matthew Crawford which I highly
recommend
and he talks about how Craftsmen will
use a strategy called jigging which
intentionally limits or constrains their
environment so they can work in a more
focused and efficient way
so again we see the Paradox limitations
can be freeing in that they enable you
to accomplish one particular task
achieve one particular goal in an
environment specifically and specially
designed for it what we find is that in
a world without limitation where
everyone can do everything Nobody ends
up doing anything
I think this is part of the story with
dating
I also mentioned as one brief aside
that arranged marriages
which is a system that has been in place
historically in many cultures
uh that exists on the opposite end of
this spectrum they are the extreme
antithesis of our current approach to
dating I said that even that even
arranged marriages
would be preferable to our current
system
and not too surprisingly that is the one
single sentence in a 14-minute
discussion of dating that the left has
latched on to so First Media Matters
published their urgent headline daily
wire host endorses arranged marriages it
is without a doubt Superior to our
system that's quoting me then my good
friend Jason Campbell over at Media
Matters posted the clip to Twitter and
from there some of the left-wing blogs
and YouTube channels picked it up and as
a consequence of all of this my inbox
this morning was full of some very
interesting commentary much of it
revolving around the theme that I am a
horrible backwards archaic caveman and I
deserve to die a painful and humiliating
death
so really just your average Wednesday I
suppose
of course contrary to the claims made by
my critics here I didn't say that
arranged marriages are the best option
just that they're better than our
current system which I'll say again
because it's true
I also think that literally anything
would be better than our current system
a national lottery pulling names out of
a hat and pairing couples up that way
would be better you could have someone
in fact I'll volunteer for this job you
could have someone just walk down the
street and point to random people like
you marry her YouTube get married and
that would be better
which speaks not to the wisdom of that
alternative but to the disastrous nature
of our modern approach
best system the one that I actually do
advocate for is as I said courtship you
might call that dating with a purpose
goal-oriented dating whatever label you
want to put on it the point is that
couples begin dating with the goal of
marriage in mind now I've been
criticized quite a bit for that
suggestion as well because it is I'm
told old-fashioned
out of touch reactionary
and I'll gladly embrace all those labels
but one of the great advantages of the
courtship courtship system is that at
the moment that either member in this
partnership realizes that they cannot or
do not do not want to marry the other
person the relationship is broken off
the marital interview process is
concluded and both can now go and seek
different applicants they don't have to
waste so much of their time
because there is a determined end point
which is either marriage
or not marriage
and once you realize you've you've
gotten to that point
where you're going to be a marriage or
you know that there's not going to be
any marriage now you can move to the
next phase which would be marriage or
just going your Separate Ways
now there's no guarantee
that anybody who adopts this strategy
will immediately find the love of their
lives and live happily ever after even
if you get married as we all know that
certainly is no guarantee that you'll
live happily ever after
because you have to live day by day and
Moment by moment we don't live in like
chunks where you can just cross some
kind of threshold and announce well I've
done this so now the next 50 years of my
life will be happy and fulfilled
doesn't work that way if you want a
happy and fulfilled life
or a happy and fulfilled marriage you
have to make that choice every day and
renew it the next day and the next day
and the day after that forever and ever
love is an act of will it's a choice
it's not merely an emotion
the emotional experience of Love is if
anything a byproduct it's not the fuel
that keeps your marriage running
the fuel is the choice you both make to
serve each other's sacrifice for each
other and remain loyal and faithful
this is another problem is this over
emphasis on emotions where emotions our
emotional
um
fulfillment on Purely an emotional level
is the entire point for a lot of people
that's what they think
and the problem is that emotions come
and go they ebb and flow emotions are
fleeting
and so they go off and they get married
and they're they're feeling the the
emotional Rush the honeymoon we talk
about the honeymoon and and these days
we say honeymoon and we're talking about
the week-long vacation that you take to
Europe or a cruise or whatever but
traditionally honeymoon is a phase of
marriage early on
and that's when your emotions are are
kicked into uh you know high gear and
and all of those those things and
there's this infatuation and when that
starts to settle down a little bit
people that are guided only by their
emotions they'll say oh well I guess
this wasn't the right one in fact I just
read an article about um uh Pamela
Anderson who unfortunately is just
divorced I think it's her fifth husband
and for some reason I read the the
article and It quotes her or someone
familiar with her as saying that oh
shoot she realized that he's not the one
so she's like in her 60s now
and she just left her fifth guy well
because he's not the one she's still
pursuing the one what do you think
you're looking for you're looking for
someone who will give you that emotional
satisfaction every second of the day
forever and a moment those emotions fade
away for even a moment then you say well
this is not the one for me
now in order to even get in the door and
have the chance to maintain a marriage
or or screw it up
you have to go into your dating quest
with a sense of purpose life in America
today
is plagued by purposelessness
you've heard me talk about this many
times because I think it's our I think
it's our Central problem
this is related to the issue of there
being too many choices it makes that
problem all the worst because how are
you supposed to know how to navigate all
the choices and select the right option
if you don't know what you're looking
for or why you're looking for it in the
first place
Americans are experiencing record levels
of Despair and anxiety not because
there's some mysterious mental illness
going around but because many people
have no sense of meaning or purpose in
their lives
this attitude is brought into their
relationships and their pursuit of
relationships and it's why the dating
scene is so miserable and marriage rates
are plummeting
I suggest
that we restore our sense of meaning and
purpose
and that's a suggestion that is treated
as controversial by those who would
prefer for everyone to remain mentally
paralyzed and in despair